>>> TONIGHT, GEORGE W. BUSH IS
TAKING HIS INCREASINGLY PUBLIC
OPPOSITION TO DONALD TRUMP TO A
NEW LEVEL.
THE 43rd PRESIDENT IS NOW
PLANNING TO HOLD A FUNDRAISER
FOR A TOP-TRUMP TARGET
REPRESENTATIVE, LIZ CHENEY.
BRIAN TODD IS JOINING US RIGHT
NOW.
BRIAN, THE ONLY TWO LIVING
REPUBLICANS TO HAVE SERVED IN
THE OVAL OFFICE ARE NOW ON A
COLLISION COURSE.
>> THEY REALLY SEEM TO BE, WOLF.
AND BY LAYING DOWN THIS MARKER
AGAINST DONALD TRUMP, GEORGE W.
BUSH AND HIS FAMILY COULD BE
SIGNALING THAT THEY ARE WILLING
TO ENGAGE TRUMP IN A BATTLE FOR
THE FUTURE OF THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY.
>> Reporter: A POLITICAL SHOT
ACROSS DONALD TRUMP'S BOW
TONIGHT FROM A REPUBLICAN
DYNASTY.
A SOURCE TELLING CNN,
FORMER-PRESIDENT GEORGE W. BUSH
WILL HOLD A FUNDRAISING EVENT
NEXT MONTH IN TEXAS FOR LIZ
CHENEY.
THE REPUBLICAN CONGRESSWOMAN
FROM WYOMING WHO HAS OPENLY
SPARRED WITH TRUMP, REJECTING
HIS BASELESS CLAIMS THAT THE
2020 ELECTION WAS STOLEN.
VOTING TO IMPEACH HIM AFTER THE
JANUARY-6th INSURRECTION.
ACTIONS WHICH LED TO CHENEY
LOSING HER HOUSE LEADERSHIP
ROLE.
>> I THINK THIS IS A BE PRETTY
BIG DEAL.
I MEAN, THIS IS THE MOST
PROMINENT EXAMPLE WE HAVE SEEN
RECENTLY OF ESTABLISHMENT
REPUBLICANS SAYING THIS IS NOT
GOING TO BE THE PARTY OF TRUMP
FROEFR.
>> Reporter: NEWS OF THE
FUNDRAISER COMES JUST DAYS AFTER
GEORGE W. BUSH SPEAKING ON THE
ANNIVERSARY OF SEPTEMBER 11th
ISSUED A STIRRING REBUKE OF THE
POLITICS OF DIVISION FOSTERED BY
TRUMP, WITHOUT MENTIONING TRUMP
BY NAME.
>> MALIGN FORCE SEEMS AT WORK IN
OUR COMMON LIFE THAT TURNS EVERY
DISAGREEMENT INTO AN ARGUMENT.
AND EVERY ARGUMENT, INTO A CLASH
OF CULTURES.
SO MUCH OF OUR POLITICS HAS
BECOME A NAKED APPEAL TO ANGER,
FEAR, AND RESENTMENT.
THAT LEADS US WORRIED ABOUT OUR
NATION AND OUR FUTURE TOGETHER.
>> Reporter: BUSH ALSO ALLUDED
TO THE MOB THAT STORMED THE
CAPITOL ON JANUARY 6th.
MOST OF WHOM WERE TRUMP
SUPPORTERS.
>> THERE IS LITTLE CULTURAL
OVERLAP BETWEEN VIOLENT
EXTREMISTS ABROAD AND VIOLENT
EXTREMISTS AT HOME.
BUT IN THEIR DISDAIN -- IN THEIR
DISREGARD FOR HUMAN LIFE, IN
THEIR DETERMINATION TO DEFILE
NATIONAL SYMBOLS, THEY ARE
CHILDREN OF THE SAME FOUL
SPIRIT.
>> Reporter: FOR YEARS, GEORGE
W. BUSH HAD LARGELY HELD HIS
TONGUE REGARDING DONALD TRUMP.
BUT BEHIND THE SCENES, ACCORDING
TO A BUSH BIOGRAPHER --
>> IN PRIVATE, HE DISLIKES
TRUMP.
HE DOESN'T LIKE HIS STYLE.
AND HE DOESN'T LIKE THE FACT
THAT HE HAS ERODED A LOT OF THE
THINGS THAT GEORGE W. BUSH AND
GEORGE HW BUSH, HIS FATHER, OF
COURSE, BEFORE HIM, HAD HELPED
BUILD UP.
>> Reporter: ANALYSTS SAY THERE
IS ALSO DEEP RESENTMENT IN THE
BUSH FAMILY OF TRUMP'S
RELENTLESS PERSONAL ATTACKS ON
JEB BUSH DURING THE 2016
REPUBLICAN PRIMARY RACE.
>> THIS GUY BUSH.
HE IS LIKE LOW ENERGY, RIGHT?
>> THIS IS A TOUGH BUSINESS TO
RUN FOR PRESIDENT.
>> YOU ARE A TOUGH GUY, JEB, I
KNOW.
>> AND WE NEED TO HAVE A
LEADER --
>> Reporter: TONIGHT, IT COULD
WELL BE SHAPING UP AS A BATTLE
BETWEEN TRUMP AND THE BUSH
FAMILY FOR THE SOUL OF THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
>> I THINK GEORGE W. BUSH HAS
DECIDED THAT HE NEEDS TO SAVE
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY AND HE
NEEDS TO SAVE IT FROM DONALD
TRUMP.
>> Reporter: AND DONALD TRUMP,
FOR HIS PART, ISSUED A
BLISTERING STATEMENT FOLLOWING
GEORGE W. BUSH'S SPEECH ON
SEPTEMBER 11th.
TRUMP SAYING THE WORLD TRADE
CENTER CAME DOWN DURING BUSH'S
WATCH, AND T